Welcome back.
We are now going to start
a new section.
This is going to be section 6.
It starts on page 407 of the
official SAT study guide.
Let's get started with some
problems. So let's see this
first problem.
Just so you know, they tend to
be tricky, but really fast
problems. And sometimes they're
just really easy and
fast. But they tend to be
problems that you should be
able to get, hopefully,
in a few seconds.
So if your plan of attack
immediately tells you will
take you three or four minutes,
your plan of attack
might be non-optimal.
It maybe correct,
but non-optimal.
So the first question
is, x plus 2/x is
equal to 5 plus 2/5.
And I was actually just looking
at this problem right
before we started this video.
And well, anyway, this is a
pretty neat problem because
this falls into the category
of, there's two plans of
attacks here.
One will take you some time,
and involves quadratics.
The other plan of attack is
ultra fast, so this is, if x
plus 2/x is equal to 5 plus 2/5,
then x can equal which of
the following?
And they give some choices.
They give the choice, 1/5.
They give the choice, 4/5.
They give the choice, 1,
5/2, and 5, right?
These are the choices
they give.
So if you see this on a algebra
test, your natural
reaction is, well, let
me solve for x.
And so you would add 5 plus
2/5, you get some fraction
there, 27/5.
You'd multiply both
sides by x.
You'd get x squared plus 2
is equal to 27 over 5x.
You'd have a quadratic.
You would want to factor that or
use quadratic equations, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
That would take you some time,
and considering this is the
first problem, that's
not going to
be the plan of attack.
So let me ask you, do you
see a pattern here?
Do these two sides
look the same?
Well, they kind of do, right?
We have an x here, an x here.
We have a 2 here, right?
We have a 2 in both places.
We have a plus in both places.
But the only difference is,
wherever I see an x on the
left hand side, I see a 5
on the right hand side.
So does something
jump out at you?
Well sure, if I just replace x
with 5, it's going to equal
this, right?
Because if I just put 5-- x
equals 5-- you get 5 plus 2/5
is equal to 5 plus 2/5.
So this is the answer.
So it could have literally taken
you about two seconds.
And I have to admit, when I
first looked at this, I
thought, the first question
is a quadratic?
I said, that can't be the way.
And I looked at it a little
bit longer, about three
seconds longer, and I
said, oh, this is
just pattern matching.
Let's move on to the next
question-- Image, clear image.
Image, invert colors--
OK, so they have a
right triangle here.
Let be draw the right
triangle.
Not a wrong triangle,
a right triangle.
Let me get the paint tool.
I'll draw this edge now
with my free hand,
my shaky free hand.
And they say this side
is 2, this side is y.
this side is x.
This , of course, is
the hypoteneuse.
And they say, in the right
triangle above, If x is equal
to 3, what is the value of y?
Well, this is just straight up
Pythagorean theorem, right?
This is the hypoteneuse,
y is the hypoteneuse.
So y squared is going to equal
this side, 4-- 2 squared--
plus this side, 3 squared.
So y squared is going
to equal 4 plus 9.
y squared is going
to equal 13.
y is equal to the square
root of 13.
And that is choice A.
This was just straight up
Pythagorean theorem, nothing
tricky there, you just kind of
kind of chug through it.
I'm assuming I didn't
do something wrong.
Well anyway, let's assume that
and then move forward.
I will now switch colors for
the sake of variety.
OK, number 3.
It says all numbers that are
divisible by both 2 and 6, are
also divisible by 4.
Right.
OK, that's cool.
Which of the following numbers
can be used to show that the
statement above is false?
So they're saying all numbers
that are divisible by both 2
and 6-- so this is what the
statement is saying.
Then it means that you're
going to be
divisible by 4, right?
So we want to prove that this
statement is wrong.
So what we have to find is, some
number that is divisible
by 2 and 6, that's not
divisible by 4.
And we could actually just
look at the choices.
They give us some choices,
4, 8, 12, 18, 24.
Well, 4 isn't even divisible
by 2 and 6, so
that doesn't work.
8 isn't even divisible by 2 and
6, so that doesn't work.
12 is divisible by 2 and 6, but
it's also divisible by 4,
so it doesn't disprove
this statement.
So, you can't say that.
18 is divisible by
2 and 6, right?
Is it divisible by 4?
No.
So this is our answer.
The example 18 is an example of
a number divisble by 2 and
6, and is not divisible by 4.
So this proves that this is
an incorrect statement.
Number 4.
In the figure above, let me draw
this figure above, and
I'll switch colors.
This is my rectangle, and then
there's going to be a circle.
I have a shaky hand.
The circle looks something
like that.
OK, and then we have side
B, A, C, and D.
It says, in the figure above,
the circle is tangent to sides
BC and AD-- tangent means
it just touches
at one point, right?
of the 8 by 12 rectangle ABCD.
So they're saying this is
an 8 by 12 rectangle.
And is it's approxmately drawn--
well can assume that
this is going to be the 8 side
and this is the 12 side
because it's longer.
What is the area
of the circle?
Well, what's the formula
for area of a circle?
Its area is equal to pi r
squared, where r is the radius
of the circle.
So let's draw that radius
So the radius of the circle is
going to be this line right
here, right?
That's the radius, which
is half the diameter.
Well, what's the diameter?
Well, the diameter is
this whole length.
So the diameter is 8, right?
So the radius is going
to be half of 8.
So we know the radius
is 4, and then we
just use the formula.
We know this is going to be 4
because this is also 4, right?
This is also 4, because
its side is 8.
This top side could have been
12 billion units wide and it
wouldn't have mattered, right?
So we know the radius is 4, so
we say, area is equal to pi
times 4 squared.
Area is equal to 16 pi,
and that is choice A.
All right, the next problem
looks like it's more involved,
and I only have two minutes left
in this video, so I will
do it in the next video.
I'll see you soon.